if you've been completely emptying and
deleting your GTO engine scene tree when
changing levels or loading scenes in
your game this tutorial will change how
you think about your scene structure
these tutorials are part of a long
series of user interface tutorials for
gato and as always you can grab the
source files for this and all of my gato
tutorials on my patreon in this video
we'll set up a scene container structure
where we can load and unload scenes
without deleting everything in the tree
this means less saving and loading data
between different scenes and in fact you
can just keep things like your UI or
your player scene untouched with this
setup the idea is we create a main scene
that will contain our three main game
components 3D 2D and UI these containers
will hold any scam we load and unload
and everything will be controlled via
the main game controller script first
create a new scene with a basic node as
the root name this something like game
controller and attach a new script at a
base node 3D node 2D and control node as
children and name then World 3D World 2D
and GUI the game controller script will
contain functions that load and unload
scenes remember we're doing this
manually so we have more flexibility in
what we actually do with the old scenes
we don't have to delete them we could
just hide them or remove them from the
tree you may be asking why does this
matter first I suggest you check out the
link in the description for a more
in-depth explanation of the pros and the
cons but basically it boils down some
memory and data deleting a scener node
removes it from memory and you have no
access to its data hiding a scene keeps
the data accessible and it will still
process an update but do this too much
and it could bog down the CPU removing a
scene keeps it in memory but it no
longer updates with new data it's easy
to add to the tree again but the data
within the scene could become old we
want this game controller script to be
accessible everywhere so we need a
global autoload script and you can do
that by going to project settings
autoload and adding a new node and the
global script at a variable game
controller and set it to the game
controller type in the game controller
script set class name to game controller
and add this line to the ready function
to set the variable reference in the
global script you should now be able to
access the script from any other node or
script at export variables for the three
scene types 3D 2D and control and set
those in the inspector add three more
variables to hold a currently loaded
scene for each I've loaded my splash
screen manager from the last episode in
the GUI spot and have set that not as
the current GUI scene this could be your
own scene or you can load your first
scene dynamically in script later then
we add the first of three similar
functions change GUI scene this function
takes a parameter from the new scene we
want which will be the scene location in
the file system a delete Boolean for if
we want to delete the old scene and a
keep running Boolean for when we want to
just hide the scene and keep it running
in the background this option only
matters if we don't delete the old scene
in the function check if the the current
GUI scene is null if it's not then we
check if we want to delete it if we do
we free the scene if we want to keep it
and keep it running we set the visible
property to false if we don't want to
run it we remove it but keep it in
memory then we load and instantiate the
new scene add that scene as a trial to
the GUI container node and set the
current GUI scene to the new scene you
could make this more complex in your
handling of the scenes but this is a
basic setup that will load and unload
your scenes create the same function
with adjusted references to 2D and 3D in
these two other functions we can now
test our scene change in my splash
screen manager we currently use the
change scene to packed function when we
press a key to skip the splash screens
now we can replace that with this line
to load our main menu scene when we
press a key
[Music]